so tonight I thought we would go over a
slightly unusual opening it's been like
months since anything has actually been
like posted by me we're backlogged so
much so it's hard to take viewer
suggestions every time but I'm going to
show a little secret weapon that I'd
like to use against the French defense
so after the moves efore ecigs d4 d5
so far everything's normal we will be
looking at the tirage variation with
Knight - d - of course there's there's
lots of other moves you can play Knight
to c3 a very logical way to protect your
a pawn you can push the advanced
variation or you can exchange in Aaron
Aaron Lynn is in the audience and he
agrees with that statement so we're off
to a good start
ok but tonight we're going to look at
night 2 d2 which if you've never seen it
before ok that looks a little bit
strange
you put a knight in front of your Bishop
in front of your Queen but it does have
the point that it eliminates any
variations you might have with Bishop to
b4 so the window where is right out
because you would just place see 3 and
you might have a very aggressive
intentions in the future you might play
moves like 'if I've and f4 and only then
put one of your Knights on f3 gaining
lots of space on the King side going in
for an attack and there's a couple of
different ways black can respond in this
position perhaps the most popular is is
Knight to f6 and then you'll get some
closed positions like this and your plan
over the next few moves is to play C 5
Knight to c6 and you attack the center
so this would be a very popular way if
you prefer open positions you might want
to look at the move c5 which is going to
guarantee that some of these pawns take
each other and you get a nice wide open
position nothing wrong with that you can
Danny Machuca it up and go for the the
Rubinstein variation you can just take
which we saw in a game today so we saw
Wesley so play the white side of this
against the Cobian so for Kobe NSYNC we
will talk about the result
so that's also possible but there's also
another way you can try to immediately
take advantage of the placement of this
night and that's with the the
strange-looking do you know it
this also is a move but we won't be
looking at it today right yeah this is
also moved this is a move like as long
as you're like waiting and not doing
anything then it's a move so there's
quite a lot of moves here but we'll be
looking at the fourth most popular
Knight to c6 so a very unusual move this
is the we marred variation but uh okay
immediately you are attacking the center
but it does look like you know you're
committing a big cardinal sin here
because now how are you ever going to
play C five and attack the center so it
looks very strange it looks a little
dubious maybe but uh I've actually had a
lot of opponents I was playing this in a
blitz game a couple days ago just like
outside after the ad the championship
was over and somebody played the move e5
which he was a relatively good player
too you know but I I just took this and
and there's no trick here you just went
upon so there's just no compensation so
how how could we defend this pawn
there's a there's two main ways perhaps
the best is to do it with a piece okay
but I find in a lot of games especially
in blitz people have a tendency to play
the move c3 so I'd like to start here
we'll take a look at this and then we'll
go back to Knight to f3 okay and so
probably you've surprised your opponent
on move three and then usually you
surprise them again on move four because
I've had a lot of people we're playing
quick games but they've thought a lot of
move three then they think a lot here
does anyone know what the most popular
move is here for black wonder what you
guys would would do here
anyway
just develop okay so this is this is
possible but it probably wouldn't
surprise them they're expecting that and
then they can follow up with E 5 and f 4
and put the other night on F 3 and and
get castled though this this should be
playable it's just if you play this way
you'll you might sometimes say why don't
I have a pawn here on c5 but the most
popular move e5 so this is a it's just
quite different than most
you know French defenses that you may
play because you immediately you know
they thought normally the French you
just keep that on e6 you love you love
hemming in your Bishop but my comer was
here so we had to liberate our bishop it
was only fair if he wasn't here we won't
be able to show this variation I do want
to show one variation not because it's
good but because it has a funny name so
here okay the most common move is here
and you have thoughts of if they play
Bishop to d3 maybe you can play a 5 e 5
is also a strong move
so most people here they actually play
this this unusual move so they don't
want to leave this guy in a pin but I
want to just mention this move only
because it has a very funny name so if
anyone can tell me the name of this
variation I'll give you a really big
prize because it's not played very often
but I'll give you guys give you guys a
chance alright this is the Thunder bunny
variation so okay and it's not even
necessarily very good but as a funny
name so you might want to play it just
for that reason alone but okay all right
we'll go back and we'll look at a c3
here and we'll look at the main move e5
okay so now there's a lot of tension in
the center so white has to decide what
he's going to do here in the most common
response is to take on d5 so we'll come
back to that you might also be wondering
well what if they take instead right
here on e5
okay and there's probably two moves you
can consider you'll either take on e4 or
you'll take on e5 the most common is to
take on e4 and already there's some some
interesting options for white white
stride some very unusual stuff here we
got quite a big audience so I guess what
would you guys do with the white pieces
here there's there several possible
moves Bishop b5 okay yeah and this is
very thematic in this sort of variation
you play you put your Bishop here a lot
more than you put it on d3 in these
lines I suppose if I have time I'll
protect this guy and then I won't know
any more theory after this because it's
not a lot of people play Bishop to b5
but okay it's a good move I guess you
might be wondering well what happens if
I just take this that might be your
first thought
some people are shaking their heads
though in disagreement but okay in a
variation like this you just can't
really be any worse here as black they
can play a move like this f6 is the only
move humans I've ever played here but
there's also this possible move very
tricky then the point is even if you you
double my pawns you'll notice it's kind
of hard for white to develop so if you
if you think about this position for a
little bit it might be hard to find a
good move here for white so okay if you
put your your King here you know you can
run into some Bishop f5 it's hard too
hard to do a lot of things I don't know
how you develop so actually black is not
worse here this is a fine way for him to
play but we'll go back here instead why
just also tried some other creative
moves such as Queen to a4 and now we'll
get a variation like this that'll be
just very very equal so we'll do some
stuff and then okay we'll trade and all
right let's even go a few most further
we can we can kick this guy back and
okay so again when you do play this
variation you Rick's you risk having
really really equal positions but okay
you're playing black so you equalize
pretty fair that's fine and if you're
playing the French take
also play the exchange variation so
you're used to equal positions if you
play the French enough
this also is a possible move okay and
you get kind of a funny position
sometimes we're both queens are in the
way on the e-file
but okay this is completely equal as
well so not a very testing replied to e5
if they just decide okay they're going
to they're going to take on e5 so
instead we'll focus here a little bit on
the the main move okay our Knights
attacked we will take this end white
should again develop his pieces but uh
this has actually been played quite
frequently and after you take back your
knight is going to jump into d3 so
people seem to like this variation they
allow this check and you get the the
bishops so you have the two bishops
you're a little bit behind in
development here but if you can keep
white from ever castling then you're
you're doing pretty fine so okay you
shouldn't really have any trouble as
black in this line either but okay so
that's sort of what happens when they
play c3 normally you just get a equal or
a better position so that's why most
people prefer in this our main move here
Knight G to f3 so now if I were running
the tournament and I'm not running
Monday night mayhem if you guys thought
I was crazy just wait until we let Mike
come and be the director of it he's
going to do all sorts of wild crazy
stuff I would start in this position and
have it be White's turn to move but who
knows what that crazy guy will will
decide you'll probably just end up
playing the two knights and none of this
will be relevant for for anything all
right
but ok we'll look at the main move here
now what would you guys do is as black
okay so you've you've guarded the e5
square that's one benefit how would you
guys continue here I guess
and it should be an easy one trying to
warm you guys up okay so you if you take
the pawn which might actually be more
playable than it it first appears okay
you do have a problem that you probably
never going to play e5 and normally on
these lines you do again want to have
the move c5 possible so instead if
you're not going to play the move c5
another common break is to play f6 but
you would have to first encourage the
pawn to go to e5 and then you'll follow
it up with f6 this is the point of this
variation so okay this is the most
common move and after each five you go
back so you won't be able to play c5 in
most lines but instead you're striving
for f6 so that's how you're going to get
counter play and fight against the
center here a lot of people in blitz
they've just played this move which is
not a very accurate move in most French
lines that's where you want your bishop
to go because we no longer have a knight
on f6 so sometimes you take on h7 when
the king's castle and you checkmate them
so that's normally a good square but
here you can just play the move Knight
to b4 so you're then going to get the
bishop or if he goes back now you do
have time to play c5 and okay they can
attack you and you can go back and
you'll get a line we can even show it
from from the start here let's play it
slightly different variations so we can
compare if we play this this line and
okay f4 is a move but we'll play this
variation normally white would prefer to
have the bishop on d3 it's a more
aggressive post for the bishop it's okay
it's a balling the the H pawn over there
so on black castles sometimes you can
sacrifice but okay in this variation we
saw the to be here which would be a much
more passive move so you can get a
better position in this line let's just
group
so we can see here this would be an
improved version and I've had this
position several times like in blitz so
okay it's just a slightly better version
than before
black normally plays Queen b6 pretty
early and he tries to get lots of
pressure on the center alright so
instead we'll go here and the main move
against you know like when the top
grandmasters play this is Knight to b3
so we'll take a look at that
but in my experience and I've played
this in many tournament games and I've
played it on the internet a lot and I've
never played and I've never faced Knight
to b3 here even though it's sort of the
main move at the top level so it is
worth looking at c3 because this is what
everybody seems to like to do and your
normal plan of just playing Bishop to d3
is actually not the most accurate plan
here for white which is why this is a
great surprise weapon you know they they
very often miss play this and they miss
play it early on but okay
it's our it's our turn so I guess what
are we going to do here we're going to
go ahead and play f6 alright and they
almost always take and now how to take
back we have we have three different
ways and in you know a lot of lines in
the tirage you know you just take back
with your knight almost on instinct
because okay you're unblocked you're
your bishop and you might be able to go
somewhere in the future but in this line
it's actually very good to take back
with the Queen and at some point you
know maybe you'll play Bishop d6 and
you'll Castle you're going to play the
move e5 and get rid of your only
weakness and liberate your LightSquared
Bishop so if you're able to play e5 you
know if that's what you're planning it's
nice to have all of your pieces here you
can even have a bishop on d6 looking at
it so you're probably going to get to
play e5 and get rid of your weakness and
if you can play e5 under favorable
circumstances in general it's going to
mean you're better so let's say for
example Bishop to d3 seems very common
and you might be able to play e5 right
away but
okay let's pretend like we're good
players and develop all our pieces and
castle now there's some things that can
happen here I want to point out a few
mistakes that a black can make because
in general what your next few moves you
want it to be is King h8 which is very
important in a lot of positions and only
then a five so but I'll make sort of a
you know a benign move that's a move
that a white might play in this position
okay nothing nothing wrong with that
and now after e5 white actually has a
really strong move here so it might take
you by surprise and based off the fact
that perhaps you should have had your
King over here to not suffer this
problem what do you guys think white
should play in this position it's about
to get very tactical awesome Queen to b3
excellent move so okay you're attacking
the pawn and the problem is there's not
a really good way to defend it if for
example Knight to b6 do we see another
good move for white hair
so this would be you know sort of I can
see a lot of players getting surprised
when this move appears on the board it's
probably not the move you would first
think of and you might think this move
is impossible but actually the move
Knight to e4 is very good yeah so
there's right so the pawn is pinned and
you're guaranteed to pick up the bishop
so let's let's make another mistake
though which will be similar to
something we're going to see okay and
here might not be such a mistake but
okay if we take here White has another
tactic man today just keep coming
Bishop takes pawn all right there's only
one pawn I can take I can't make fun of
you if by saying some other pawn okay
Bishop takes pawn and okay you'd have to
play King 2h a so hopefully everybody
sees what would happen on this move
Knight to g5 and you're going to lose
your queen
so okay which is also a problem in this
other variation so let's go back here
we'll say this move and we just we're
going to play e5 right away we're gonna
be a little ambitious okay and now if I
you know if I see this little the trick
here
okay I'm gonna unpin you know I'm not
I'm gonna unpin here so now I'm just
starting to play here you'd again see a
similar tactic
yeah Bishop takes h7 and again she can
play here what's funny about this too is
it's it's happened in a few games but
black is one every time so it's also
hard to play white in this position
that's not even though you're down upon
and the computer is like yeah this is
great for white it's it is hard to play
as a human because you know you're gonna
play here and then you're going to take
this thing and then you're going to win
so that happens a lot but but yeah you
should be able to just go back and
everything's fine but okay it's hard
it's hard for both sides to play that
position all right it's that's just sort
of a general overview we'll go now to a
game assuming I can find it let's see if
I can I can even find it this is the
game between Alexander stripping ski and
Hikaru Nakamura from the 2012 US
Championship so okay we see her karo is
again the the highest rated player in
the championship this year by the time
this you see this you'll have known if
he won or not maybe Cara 101 maybe so
one maybe Akshay Andhra one that'd be
something but so we'll know who's going
to win but he's in this again and so
here he was playing with the black
pieces and okay we'll see he got the
French defense and after after this move
he played the gwee marred okay so he
attacked the pawn and his opponent you
know very very good grandmaster he
decided to play the following variation
with Knight to b3 and this move is a
game is like 71 moves long so we'll go
through it a little bit faster than
usual
okay Knight to b3 and a very common move
that black wants to play in this
position is something you might not
think of but a5 getting a little bit
more space you'll play a4 if if they let
you and also you want to play moves like
b6 and Bishop to a6 to trade off the
bishops because this Bishop will at some
point go to d3 and that'll be one of
white strongest pieces because again
with the pawn on e5 you don't have a
knight on f6 so there might be
sacrificial ideas so training off these
light squared bishop suspect behind all
these pawns is a very good idea so his
opponent didn't let him play a four he
played a for himself okay and now the
most common move is b6 so that's what
you could maybe expect but okay but he
probably had this prepared and he
decided to go for this line with Bishop
to e7 okay and now white played Bishop
to b5 so now playing b6 is not a very
good move so some people seem to get it
but I guess I guess for others you know
that would be bad so okay he's fighting
against blacks plan very good and now
you know you might think oh maybe he's
just going to castle but he actually
went after the bishop he played Knight
to a seven okay so I would I would like
to take your Bishop if you'd let me
so the bishop went back it's worth
noting maybe maybe some greedy people
want to take this it does just feel it
feels kind of wrong you're falling
behind in development and actually now
black would have a tactic so let's see
what would have happened if he if he
took this pawn yeah Knight takes Bishop
all right I'll take back
alright I'll go back and then you want
to trade these guys and then I'm up a
pond but my night is a little silly no
okay that's not the most testing move
you actually have a an even better
tactic but that was like a good idea
push the pawn up man so many pawn second
Bush Bishop on ok excellent and you
attack to pieces ok so that be the
tactic they would win so I that move is
impossible so after Knight to a 7 he
just backed up his Bishop he went to d3
and now we saw b6
ok we're thinking what's what's kind of
nice is okay now we will get to play a
move like c5 we'll put our knight back
on c6 maybe we'll play Bishop a6 you
know we'll trade those guys off it's
very easy to to play black here and now
a very interesting moves so his opponent
he sees that idea he knows c5 is about
to come so he plays a very interesting
move
he plays Bishop to d2 and the point is
after it moved like c5 and after he
takes this is what actually happened
he's preventing you from taking with the
pawn which is desirable because then you
might be able to push this pawn and
cause a lot of problems for white but
obviously this guy would be hanging so
both captures are actually relatively
fine here okay so either way you would
capture would actually just went upon so
he wasn't able to take back that way but
okay he said fine I'll just take back
with a knight and now if you don't take
me I'll take your bishop or I'll take
that the knight on B 3 so okay white
took this and now you did get to take
back with upon and it is sort of
important it's nice that he controls the
d4 square so this is sort of been an
opening success for black at least in my
opinion
he has some open lines on the Queen side
white you know doesn't have a big attack
coming just yet and okay he might get to
get his plan of trading off these
bishops of the near future he's going to
move this guy and then he's going to get
to play Bishop to a6
he decided first
now after the movie three preventing c4
which is also an annoying move he
castled and now okay he's doing
everything he can to sort of fight
against the future idea Knight to c6 the
bishop went back in and okay we do
intend to at some point play this move
so Queen to b6 makes a lot of sense and
on your next move you can go try to
trade the bishops so this is this has
been pretty good for for him so far so
castles bishop basics okay he's done all
of the plans that he wanted to do and
okay we're out of the opening and now
we're going to see the middle game and
white made sort of an interesting
decision here I don't know how many
people would have considered playing
this move but he played c4 which okay
it's kind of traps the bishop in a
little bit so the bishop is is trapped
in for the moment also at just the right
moment we might be able to play a move
like d4 and this might actually be
playable even though there is a way for
black to win upon here he could take
this and take here and okay hákarl
probably didn't want to give away his
pawn but maybe he has some compensation
here because okay we have some pressure
on this file we have a passed pawn but
okay you know not not blundering your
pawns is also a good strategy in chess
so he instead played Bishop to b7
okay so the rope came over in some lines
you know you might want to have your
your rope here we'll see why in just a
just a minute you might want to keep
your book on a1 okay his knight jumped
in and so he's moved his pieces away to
try to show that this guy is a little
bit off sides maybe if I can just play
this move to if I won't be able to use
all of these squares ever but okay you
might be a little trapped over there and
again sort of a another interesting
decision late to g5 okay in white you
know might be thinking of a an attack
here so he has the potential for Queen
to h5 he has the potential for f4 f5
here's the potential to take the knight
and then sorry
take the knight and then swing the the
rook over somewhere so there's a lot of
attacking ideas here for white
alright so Carlos first of all said you
know go away and you could just go back
to f3 but uh okay he went back to h3 and
this is this is the famous maneuver from
France Machuca 2016 where I did the same
thing only unlike the game I did this
and it was really strong in my game so
perhaps he had seen that even though it
was played for Game four years before
but uh I guess he knew so he did that
but he didn't follow it up the same way
I did because it's a different position
okay instead now we got to move d5 or d4
excuse me so okay we've we've improved
this bishop now he has a lot of scope we
got the past pawn
thanks for looking pretty good and okay
Knight to f4
and now one thing is okay you can go
here to contest the night which is
actually going to happen in the game and
you also might be thinking of Knight to
h5 so let me pass a couple times let's
just get this guy here so here just to
demonstrate the threat you know we
wasted time with black or this is
actually a quite a dangerous position so
there's all these sacrifices you can
take this and this and the Queen's
coming in so the best move here is okay
you can take on h6 that guy's in the
lead of the tournament so I guess he
knows everything about the opening he's
like I know it all yep I got it okay
and we come in and then we threaten
checkmate if you don't wanna get made it
you know you can go here but this is
this is just terrible so there's all
these sacrificial ideas that you you got
to be aware of with the night here so he
decided okay these guys may become
targets in the future and he put his
King on h7 and this game was really
memorable because the Cardo
you know he set up his pieces in a
really interesting way in this game so
we'll see it okay white just gets his
his all the rook into the game and now a
an unusual move rook to g8 so he has
some some defensive ideas we'll get to
it so after the night went back you're
going to like this move to the other
Rick one to f8 alright so just yeah so
what could this what could this all be
about we're going to see in just a
second all right so the night took and
here's why this this rook may want to
still be on a1 because in any variation
where this occurs you know you might
want to be able to push this pawn down
the board but okay this is this should
be fine for white okay check and you're
probably thinking okay he could move his
king or he could block with his pawn
that's what he decided to do and okay
white played here maybe not the best
move but okay you got big control here
ovary five alright that's that's good
but okay
if black doesn't get checkmated then
he's doing alright in this position and
okay so it's and then a lot of
interesting stuff happened we'll just
get to the main action here g5 and I
guess I would like to ask the audience
in starting next month we're going to
have on Tuesdays at 6:30 we'll have
strategy sessions with Jonathan trance
and in that class maybe we'll do a lot
of positions like this where I'll give
you a position in Alaska what how would
you rearrange your pieces here with
black so it's at this moment that I kind
of want to take a second and see do a
little planning exercise if you guys are
playing black what do you think the
optimal square for all of your pieces is
and whenever I say that to kids they say
crazy stuff like oh I wrote over here
and the Queen here and like pawns here
like I want rooks here and here
checkmate you know but okay
within reason just take a minute and see
how what do you guys set up your pieces
here with black because what he did is
very very interesting so the only piece
that's really well placed is this bishop
now he's going to move all of his other
pieces around he's going to move his
rooks and his King and his Bishop and
his Queen this other bishop I mean and
they're all going to find better squares
so okay where where would you guys put
this maybe this is the easiest I don't
know what would you guys put this bishop
yeah c7 right so okay c7 that'd be a
good square you got you got pressure on
the pawn okay the Queen what should we
do with her
there's probably a couple different
reasonable squares you can put your your
queen on so she's not not really doing
anything on this diagonal or file here
where would she be better
well if you're going to put your Bishop
on c7 we'll imagine the bishop is on c7
well you could put your your Queen over
here you know line them up you could
also put the Queen over here get some
some pressure on the Jeep on
okay so that'd be an improvement and
what about this guy what do you think
that guy is going to go you could you
could stay there but uh yeah that's a
yeah that's very closely ie7 was
suggested and yet this guy is going to
go this way you know he's going to start
running that way which means he needs to
rearrange his his rooks slightly so
we're going to see all of that okay so
he gets out of the way so he can play
rook to g6
which he plays which okay defends the
pawn and any time sometimes you want to
be defending your other pond to okay
there's many variations where that is
important so okay now the king is has an
escape he's going to run to the Queen
side very interesting okay so that's
where the we know where the Queen's
going and so he just he rearranges all
of his pieces it's a very very nice
manoeuvring game and okay his opponent
said all right nakamoto's running his
king over to the Queen side he's pretty
good I'll do the same thing
alright so both Kings Castle kingside
and now they're going to run over to the
other side okay so that that all
happened the bishop came in alright and
he decided to put his Queen on this
square let me make some sense okay so
there's been been some shuffling and yes
a very very interesting maneuver in game
and now another good move was played
f-five so exploiting the fact that
there's a pin so this would this would
be a mistake that even the person
walking in the door can see do you see
what black would play here
if I if I put my mouse here then do you
see it okay
all right excellent yeah so f5 okay
another good move and maybe he's going
to play F for himself and okay this it
seems like all of a sudden blacks pieces
really untangled and they're they're
looking a lot better than whites pieces
this guy is still sort of trapped over
here
the queen is trapped over here this guy
is about to be locked out so all right
black has managed to just improve his
pieces slowly and slowly he's out
playing his uh his grandmaster opponent
so okay Bishop h2 he's you know getting
ready to get off of this diagonal
because he knows it's going to get
blocked so he was ready for that you
know another another good move okay it's
a queen move Queen b8 does make a make a
lot of sense
wonder why I wasn't played I mean they
suppose I just defend and then it's well
it's not even that hard to attack it
again really but okay
right yeah and I might not even take it
right away right I'll go over here
yeah and then and then I'll take it
yeah okay
so but anyway he instead decided on
Queen f8 also a very good square with
the same sort of idea you know maybe he
gets to play Queen a5 and put some
pressure on the pawn here okay and here
white beta made a interesting and brave
decision he decided to sacrifice so he
took the pun okay and then he gets to
take back all right so we're we're
looking good so far so we have to you
know move our Bishop back so you got two
ponds for your piece your rook is decent
on that diagonal all very good and you
do have to passed pawns so is this
enough for white that's the the big
question it's certainly the dynamic way
to play and okay but you know what's now
going to get some some pretty good
pieces as Queen is still offsides but
okay so after this move he's now he gets
to also liberate his bishop this is
another point so he might be able to go
to c4 we have some pressure here and he
might be able to go to d3 because you'll
notice it's not very easy to get this
rook out of the way because if this you
know moves here or say then we might be
able to take your H pawn so maybe we
can't but okay but in any case you
decide to play here and this move
immediately is actually a big mistake
because you have this this
counter-attacking move where you so even
if you take this this is really good for
black so okay instead rook to d6
sacrificing even more
so he took and okay you probably don't
want to take this way giving my my queen
some access into the Kings side but okay
alright and let's see so for the moment
it's a it's a rook that you're down here
obviously you still have your your
passed pawns you're up up some pawns and
now you're going to get a little bit of
material back okay so you're going to
win some material you improve his bishop
and then there was some traits okay
so this is the position we've reached so
black is up a bishop but again you still
have these ponds so that is that is a
lot of counter play and again I guess I
know I've had students that really have
difficulty finding a good plan in these
endgame situations so I guess if I just
like to know what you guys would do here
with white it's white to move so what do
you think his plan is and then we'll
figure out what blacks plan might be as
well to take over the C file would you
start by moving your king is this is
this what you
mm-hmm and then you just want to come
and get that the C file let's see so
even if you were there yeah I guess I
mean I'd put my rook over here then I
don't know how you're ever going to
enter but okay he dad he had the idea of
going after this weakness which in a lot
of in games that's one of the things
that you want to look for you want to
say what's weak and then can I just go
attack it so this yes this is the target
that he was looking at he decides all
right I'm gonna go get that pawn there's
probably other plans you're taking this
e-file also seems to make a lot of sense
and you might even end up doing
something similar we have some pressure
here all right and maybe for black you
think in okay maybe I can attack here
okay that probably is easy to defend
maybe I can attack this guy there's some
weaknesses there if I it's gonna be hard
to imagine my rook you know breaking in
because you're going to probably control
the file before me but uh okay then the
G pawn might also be a target in the
future so he brought his rook in he's
just he's just going here and after this
move all right
rook to d4 and now he decided just just
to move his king up
okay so I didn't think yeah the obvious
move that I think we all would well
might play just immediately right you
just take the pawn and then after the
rook takes what he was probably worried
about is a position like this where his
pieces end up getting really active so
rook to b8 must be what he was afraid of
and after a move like this if the rook
comes over you're sort of paralyzed as
black it's not very easy to move your
pieces you can get this guy back into
the game but it's going to cost you a
pub and okay white stud Neely has some
activity and your your pieces don't make
a whole lot of sense so he decided
instead I'm going to prefer the activity
of my pieces over you know you trying to
win a little bit of material keep the
material a little bit more equal so he
gave up yet another pawn okay
so white is up white has three pawns for
the bishop which seems fair enough and
look at this three passed pawns okay
very very interesting that should
probably give white enough counter play
but uh okay let's see he's probably but
now he gets to stop this threat so he
brings his rook back and at least now
his pieces make a lot of sense so that
was a big goal okay he brought his King
in and okay is he going here is he going
to go take this pawn well
after white started moving his pawns he
decided to switch his plans and uh okay
he's he's going to play g4
okay let's stop this guy and it's also
funny because now this guy is kind of
trapped he kind of found a way to trap
all of his pieces sort of self trap
everything and he's done it again that
seems if you want to play like strip one
ski that's what you do you got a self
trap all your pieces that's how you
that's how you make it in the US
Championship okay so this happened and
we got some trades okay maybe we would
take this pawn all right now we have a
pass pond so okay you brought us Bishop
back and now black has a pass pond all
right
so he's pushes
all right and white goes to stop the
pawn rook f8 excellent okay he blockades
just protect it it does attack something
once it does yeah it does attack
something once though okay yeah okay but
how about this maybe I'm going to check
yeah yeah no so he took and this is
actually the decisive mistake so he just
keeps sacking and this was one too many
so this move is actually a mistake but
if you look at this position I will give
away a move here that's five past funds
so then I remember watching this live -
I didn't know I didn't really know
what's going on you know it seems kind
of crazy and there's actually only one
winning move here so this also is a good
end game test for you this is a very
tricky position okay that's a lot of
past pawns but black is winning so who
can can anybody play the right move here
rook h2
um
a
Brook a - I guess I'll get this guy
going
okay yes I got a lot of ponds all I'm
pushing I'm gonna push them all hmm okay
sir Rick p8 yeah I mean show me what's
wrong with it all right that was played
I was trying to trick you so good job
you know and it's it's sort of like you
know you just please you know you want
to push you're a pawn he's like you just
just do it but he didn't do it
if you push here we okay we got a we got
to defend this and you're just in time
with your king so if we go here you know
if you start pushing
yeah we're just in time so either way
either way you push you know we're in
time so you're just in time
very well calculated so wow yeah Wow um
so he tried and said g5 okay and now
it's he goes and vacuums up the pawns
okay he gets back and okay the king is
isn't time to eat all these pawns here
so and in this position white resigned
so yeah there's a lot of incredible
stuff he did you know he maneuvered his
pieces around in a really instructive
way and even that endgame was really
tough it's not often that your opponent
has five past pawns and they're losing
but all right that was the case here
so sometimes a rook is better than five
pawns
okay so hopefully this gave you guys you
know a little little weapon you can use
it it's really good in blitz and it's
even good over the board it's good
enough to play it in the US Championship
and okay keep sending in your
submissions make sure you hit like share
subscribe and we'll see you guys next
week